1000 mal schneller als wlan solarzellen
erzeugen strom ohne sonne forscher
analysieren pferde mimik das sind nur
drei der fünf geben heute in den kriegs
und pfeifen wie vielen tieren habt ihr
schon mal genau in die augen geschaut
könnt ihr euch an die pupillen form
erinnern wenn ja könnte auch bald sagen
um welche art von tier es sich gehandelt
hat und dass alleine durch das wissen
über die pupillen form forscher der
university of california haben im zuge
einer studie über 200 tierarten in die
augen geschaut
zitat wir wollten verstehen wieso die
pupillen so sind und haben die sicht
durch eine horizontale und vertikale
öffnung im computer simuliert zitat ende
so martinez von der university of
california sie veröffentlichten ihre
studie im fachmagazin science
ihre resultate pflanzenfresser haben
horizontale augenschlitzen warum
durch diese trinken kein stöhr licht ins
auge und somit sind drohende gefahren
schnell und detailliert zu erkennen
fleischfresser dagegen schauen durch
vertikale augen schließe diese würden
dazu beitragen dass die distanz zur
nahrung leichter einzuschätzen ist in
der fachsprache der fotografie würde man
von schafen tiefe sprechen durch
unscharfe unscharfe bereiche kann das
tier dann die ungefähre entfernung
abschätzen
dieser arabische emirate sind ja bekannt
dafür nennen wir es mal finanzielle
unabhängigkeit jetzt lassen sie es dort
auch noch regnen
ein geldregen sondern echter regen in
dem wüstenstaat ist der wasserverbrauch
teilweise so hoch dass sie mit einer
heftigen wasserknappheit umgehen müssen
mit einer speziellen technik soll sich
das ändern flugzeuge sollen
salzkristalle in die wolken über den
trockenen wüstenregionen befördern wer
das sind dann kristallisationspunkte in
den wolken gekommen hofft man dass die
kristalle die wasser kombination anheben
eben durch diese kristallisationspunkte
sobald diese einen bestimmten
schwellenwert erreicht hat würde sich
das wasser aus den wolken lösen und
einen regenschauer erzeugen wenn der
regen am boden angelangt ist wird er
nach angaben des ministeriums von 130
verschiedenen speicher möglichkeiten
aufgefangen diese fassen
rund 120 millionen kubikmeter wasser die
vereinten arabischen emirate setzen
jetzt auf 15 forschergruppen die sich
nach weiteren und alternativen wasser
beschaffungsmaßnahmen erkundigen sollten
dort forschen sollen ob ein
pferdeflüsterer auch grimassen schneidet
während er sich mit den pferden
unterhält einer neuen studie zufolge
spielt die mimik bei der kommunikation
der pferde eine riesige rolle
experten der university of sussex in
brighton haben alle muskeln im pferde
knopf kopf genau betrachtet vor allem
deren zusammensetzung und bedeutung sie
nutzen dafür dass equi fax das equi
facial action coding system stammt von
fax systems das fax system wird schon
seit längerem bei uns menschen in der
psychologie angewandtes hilft dabei
mimiken zu erkennen und auszuwerten
die wissenschaftler konnten mit hilfe
des ecp wie fax überraschendes
feststellen im fachmagazin plos one
veröffentlichten sie ihre ergebnisse
pferde würden demnach einige menschliche
mimik verwenden
die genaue untersuchung der pferde mimik
könnte in zukunft ein wichtiger baustein
für die berufe seien die mit pferden zu
tun haben
solar- und photovoltaikanlagen
technologien die unseren alltag
beziehungsweise unsere sicher schon
lange schmücken eine neue derartige
technologie könnte diese jetzt
revolutionieren solar und photovoltaik
anlage können nur dann bisher energie
erzeugen wenn sonnenstrahlen auf diese
treffen amerikanische und chinesische
wissenschaftler haben im fachmagazin
advanced energy mit tirols eine neue
technologie vorgestellt das besondere an
dieser technologie ist dass diese nicht
wie ihre vorgänger von sonnenstrahlen
abhängig ist sie produziert auch strom
wenn wind und regen auf sie ein treffen
die zellen bestehen aus mehreren
schichten die einen entnehmen den
wassertropfen ihre elektrische ladung
die anderen entnehmen dem windenergie
das läuft etwas komplizierter ab kurze
erklärung eine schicht aus polymer wird
durch böen auf eine nylon schicht
gepresst und bei diesem kontakt
entstehen dann auch wieder ladung die
sich mit hilfe von elektroden nutzen
lassen die forscher konnten auch schon
erste zahlen veröffentlichen
sie konnten aus windböen ca 8 millimeter
gewinnen aus
tropfen gewann sie sogar 90 millimeter
roter laser standard weißer leser er
nicht experten der arizona state
university bündelten mehrere segmente zu
einem laser einem weißen leser das erste
mal gelangen dieses den forschern des
centre national labs in albuquerque im
jahr 2011 warum ist die arbeit der
arizona state university dann heute so
besonders
2011 wurden vier leser dazu benötigt
jetzt konnte man einen weißen
laserstrahl mit hilfe eines einzigen
kreieren
sie berichten darüber in der nature
nanotechnology zeitschrift mit dieser
neuen technologie könnte man
raumbeleuchtung ganz anders gestalten
laser könnten nicht nur licht bringen
sondern auch daten übertragen so
genannte light based wireless
communication nicht weiter sondern live
id arizona state university berichtete
dass man mit der laser leihvariante eine
bis zu 1000 mal schnellere verbindung
herstellen könnte als die des wlans wenn
es die laser leihvariante mal auf den
markt geschafft hat könnte das wlan der
vergangenheit angehören die krankheit
wird wohl auch bald die sim-karte
angehören warum und was die sim karte
ersetzen soll erfahrt ihr im video hier
oben zu rap und zum blog könnt ihr
unicom alle videos natürlich auch in der
video beschreibung und habt ihr schon
mal besondere nie mit gesichtern gesehen
bei eurer katze hund oder hamster oder
was ja auch immer habt schreibt es uns
nochmal unter dieses video in die
kommentare
vielleicht kommen da interessante
ergebnisse raus vielleicht hätte ein
oder andere was spannendes entdeckt also
bis dann bleibt dran